so hi everyone thank you for coming
sorry I've got a bit of a cold so I hope
you can still understand me well and I
won't cause too much so yeah we have to
talk about privacy-preserving techniques
with a focus on text data so I'm a data
scientist I work at a company called
people talk and we are dealing with
human resources documents and so as you
can get some sensitive information in
that kind of documents in those kind of
documents and so we've got this very
strong privacy by default and privacy by
design concepts which are very
importance to us at people dock and
that's I think that's already
interesting me before so but that's kind
of the focus of my work but you're not
going to talk about human resources
document today because what may that be
might seem a bit boring so it can
something more general so let's say you
had master of school boarding school so
your students they receive a lot of
messages from friends and relatives
relatives there has been a kind of a
problem recently there's been a high
increase in advertisement and solitudes
unsolicited messages things that the
student doesn't want to don't want to
have and it's getting very big a problem
because at breakfast time so many
increase of incoming messages by whole
yeah so it's a Wizarding boarding school
so the thing is that you want to be able
to distinguish between legitimate olds
and so-called spam and you want to do
that but of course you want to preserve
the privacy of the old communication
because you don't want to spy on a
student and you definitely don't watch
they also don't to think that you are
spying on them so you try to choose
which we can have a problem at first
because you have your headmaster so
you're really really busy you don't want
to take care of that
district getting hot I found there's so
many holes it's big problem so at first
you try some heuristics something which
is based on rules it's naturally working
that wise that I create enough also it's
not flexible enough so it's good it's
very easy for attacker to go around your
rules and still deliver their unwanted
messages so you don't have a choice
you're gonna have to collect some
information and seize its messages text
messages you know that they will include
some private information and you don't
have any of a choice of doing that so
that's the first rule of doing price
preserving machine learning is just like
don't create private information if you
don't have private data it's privacy
preserving thank you for attention if
you don't have any choice than you know
collecting some private information then
you are becoming responsible of the
safekeeping of this data that means
that's the bare minimum is to use
encryption at rest that is any any hard
drive and drive containing this data
should be encrypted when it's not used
that's like low level and of course you
should enforce best security practices
so go talk to the security force in your
company or in the company here to help
you not just here to give you annoying
advice like change your password and
you're strong this world and stuff like
that they're actually here to help you
keep your data safe and ever know the
data which is not yours you know your
users that are safe that's good at rest
so when you are not using the data and
it's taught but when you want to do
actually like machine learning you're
gonna have to train models so you have
to do something well so trying to get
back to the first rule which is don't
use private data you can try to extract
the private information from your data
set and then you're back to square one
and you can do machine learning other
ways and that's easy
I'm gonna very quickly introduce two
main
concepts which is the one of personally
I'm achieving information so which are
things like first and last name user
names email addresses that also like IP
addresses MAC addresses session IDs all
that kind of things were linked uniquely
to one individual one to one and the
other thing is viscosity of attributes
which are thing which are not sensitive
in themselves but they become sensitive
when we are linked to one individual it
could be things like medical information
financial information knowing that well
some people were wealthy some people
were not so wealthy that's not like a
privacy lake same knowing but some
people are some healing unless well it's
sad but everybody knows that but knowing
that your neighbor is owning that amount
of money or this person is suffering
from this specific illness that's major
privacy leaky and these things may more
sense in structure data so tabular data
and we can make a quick detour by this
structure data idea to really grasp the
concept and see how come we can apply
this concept back to actual text so
unstructured text data there are civil
way to remove this personal information
in structured data the easiest way is
just masking so that's like removing the
columns containing the information so
that's easy because you know that's the
email address column Cochin contains
email addresses so you remove the
columns no problem it's a great way if
you know that each line in your tables
corresponds to one user one individual
but whereas some cases well like in your
table each line is a different event and
in that way you might still want to know
that some events are linked to the same
individual even if you don't know
anything about this person so in that
way you can use things like hashing
that's a destructive way of matting
some personal information to an IG and
my time in that destructive is that you
cannot go back from the hashed ID you
cannot get back the initial value and
that's done on purpose because if you
cannot access back the initial username
or email addresses that means that's if
your data is ever leaked the attacker
cannot go back ever so that's what you
want and well basically that way you
still know that's lines 2 for an 18 are
linked to the same individual but you
don't know which individual it is in
some cases in some application is some
data pipelines you might need to have
something which is more plausible if you
just have like random hashes it won't
work or for testing purposes you you
couldn't be able to test your
pre-processing pipeline so you can use
fake data about some library like for
example in Python or a library code
faker they generate plausible the data
so you can tell them generates me
principal first and last name and you
can give them a locale so that's your
this thing match the localization you
are using if you're Germany you'll have
like German sounding first and last name
and so on and also it's really important
for street addresses which are trade
country depe knowledge so you can get
something which is plausible and the
last thing is maybe that's in this big
databases you as a data scientist you
don't need this information but this
database is shared with other people
like for example the finance department
and the finance department they also use
this data for billing purposes and so
they need to know to whom they should
send the invoice so in that's the guy
you should split your data between a non
private table which contains everything
with an ID and then you have this
private information table which link the
ID to all the personal information and
this privates information table is
really accessed on a need to be basis
enough
special security miserable setup and
that's like the bare minimum which is
recommended to be a gdpr compliant for
example so that was four tables that are
so as I said it was easy because you
know that's first-name I in the first
name columns unless they're mine even
last name currents but when you've got
like big chunk of text the first thing
is which of these tokens you get which
were the sensitive one which are
containing any private information so
this is still like a very open question
research question that's awesome
solution you can try and there are all
very very data set dependent and also
application dependence which are some
things you can try
when idea is using dictionary based
removal so if you're working for school
if you're working for company you might
have like the names of all a database
with the name of all the company
employees and you at least want to
remove all of that from the text data so
that you remove sensitive some sensitive
information it's not perfect so for
example in the span use case messages if
you remove in just the students name
you're not removing four related names
of a friend's name so we still have some
personal information but it's kind of
kind of easy to implement and it could
be a first step there is another
approach which is using an untied action
array so an entire dictionary will be
words you know which are not containing
any sensitive information and you only
keep resorts in your text the problem is
that mean you get like all common words
in a language and also all declined
version of these nouns and all
conjugated version of the labs so that
gate gets quite huge and you only keep
things which are in this huge dictionary
so that's nice yeah gets ready
that's very scalable and also your
you're losing a lot of information you
out you and all typos I do you and all
things which are both common names and
first name for example but depending of
the sensitivity of your data you're
manipulating you might want to consider
something like that
via where and the resolution is if you
are like and link text data but it's
naturally unstructured this is what I
would cut some instructors I'm thinking
about anything like forms curriculum
vitae resume anything like reports
instant messaging logs or any kind of
logs you kind of get some sort of
structures and so anything which is
following email : and then you get a
token it's probably an email address I
mean in the forum you probably fill your
email address so you can use this
underlying structure try to extract it
with regular expression and then remove
the Associated personal information
regular expression also are great for
things like emails and social security
numbers any kind of IDs company IDs so
before you tell me that that's not a
totally correct regular expression for
matching emails there exists like one
canonical form it's like 25 lines long
you can find it on Google if you need it
but you get the idea if you know that
you're working for a company and the
employee ID in this company is like 11
number eleven numbers long you might
want to match every Elven string of
eleven numbers and remove that because
it's probably probably an employee ID
the other solution is of course to use
things like named entity recognition
which are available in a shelf library
like Stacey for example they can catch a
lot of different things person's
location organization and you may want
to replace them with
a given token or and if if you got any
possibility to to to like tune with name
out to zero connection you definitely
want to have a higher recall rather than
higher precision that means you you
rather have some false positive and
removing some things which are which
could have which are not private and let
some private information last thing when
everything else has failed you can try
to have your own pseudonym ization
algorithm things like they're not to the
recognition that we train on regular
text purposes and so if you're running
anything a bit more exotic so insurance
claim human assistance document medical
report you probably want to add
something which is more fine-tuned to
your needs also there are some tools
which are domain-specific in particular
for like medical reports there are some
existing libraries which are more suited
to this kind of thing the advantages you
think search algorithm is that of course
you hopefully get more accurate on your
use case on your domain specific data
the cons is that it requires annotation
and that is it's time consuming and also
that means that someone has to look to
go through every document and then
annotate in a every private information
so since we were trying to to hand hands
privacy at the first time it's kind of a
trade-off that's at first someone has to
look through everything so we've removed
everything so here again we go back to
the structured data example we have
removed all personal information that's
great
are we good to go so that's an extract
from the school nursery in your school
and you know that's Harry has just come
out of the nursery school nursery
and you want to know hey your [ __ ]
curious what kind of medical condition
did you have and you know that is 15
years old and you know that is hugging
house Gryffindor okay so we've got only
two 15 years old boy only one in house
calendar so just by knowing public
information about Harry you are able to
to leak this magical is phony cold
condition so that's the sensitive
attributes here so so the limitation is
like the first type to to to avoid like
to lick directly some private
information but it's not enough because
some what you call obsidian inotify ask
attributes some combination of these
attributes may be unique
what's up so do identifiers for example
their age they are general zip code
affiliation that kind of things even in
the very large data sets some of these
combination end up being unique and the
thing is most of the time you don't even
really need these exact values like you
don't care that someone is 15 or 14 you
just want to know that they are under 25
so we have this possibility to like
aggregate these attributes so that's for
any combination you can guarantee that
you have at least K rows so K different
individuals matching this combination so
as I said you use ranges of aggregates
so we go back to the same the same
tables but now we've aggregated I ages
so we've got two ranges below 14 about
15 and we've also aggregated houses so
that we've get this true anonymity which
is enforced to is very small value but
this is a very small data set so now we
are good we say okay we've lost a bit of
precision not too much
but now we are not going to leak any
sensitive attributes right well why can
you tell me about Luna she's you know
she's
years old and she's in running club so
let's have a look
volley to lines of a virtual eyes
because it's too anonymous bet they both
are the same sensitive attributes so
actually a man if everything is grouped
you can still gain some information
that's why we need 200 as a favicon tab
which is El diversity so that's in each
of its care and in this group we've got
at least L different value okay keep
going in the same table bit different
because I've only keeps the people which
are under 14 to a bit more choice and I
removed entirely the mention of the
house because that was an L diverse
through diverse else and can you still
tell me something about rhythm lb so
you're just gonna highlight the five
different lines which could match Luna
and out of these five lines for at the
same disease so you know if high
probability that's Luna is suffering
from limitation sickness so L diversity
is not protecting you for statistical
attack there are always kind of array of
a kind of attacks which is like if you
are dealing with not categorical but
numerical value you might have different
numerical value but they're all in the
same range so you still know that
someone as a for example or low income
even if you don't not sure what exactly
it's the outcome is income areas that
still get an idea
so by this notion of T closeness that's
the distribution of each sensitive
attribute is roughly the same in the
group and in the overall data set but
here you see that's typically why we
need machine learning is like to
discriminate between distributions so if
you are enforced across as you kind of
lose lots of utility and your data set
survives various risk trade-off between
what
you you as a data scientist who does not
want to like break privacy you get alpha
datasets and now you can ensure that
malicious user won't get too much
information so that's a structural data
now we're making text and as you can see
there are some ways to remove things
like Minerva McGonagall so first plus
last name if you've got a good name and
GT recognition it will probably match
but if you get a phrase like a head of a
Griffin the house it is much harder to
teach you and Anna Mize that you remove
that information it should probably
remain even after should you know
amazing your data sets and if you think
about it what I would would you Emily
mais as human I would put you I mean
would you animate this phrase we do like
remove everything and just say it's a
person would you say it's someone from
the hog fat stuff so you keep the
information that's it's a teacher would
you say it's the head of some house
which is like not just any teacher or
someone will add some responsibilities
but then guys only for house so there's
a very high risk of being able to
entirely in dota 5 a person with other
information in the text once again it's
a really hard question we don't have
complete solution yet the idea one idea
might be to extract every two
identifiers and treat them as personal
and O's if I are the same or at least
aggregate them for example if you've got
a number you think it's an age you
remove it and you add age bracket
instead if you are dealing with resume
and someone is coming from Harvard you
remove Harvard and say they are coming
from an Ivy League university and that's
probably going to be the same in your
general process once again is three
application dependent but there are a
lot of information you can remove or
aggregate without using utility for you
um yeah and then you must go aggregate
them well is it enough by this
application in natural language
processing which is called a four-ship a
traditional algorithm which aims
well discovering who wrote a certain
piece of text so as you see it really
depends on your application but in some
case you you might not be able to really
remove all private information from your
data set without destroying the data
entirely so something to think about
but ok you've tried to do something on
your data set but we you are not going
to expose your data sets to your
end-user anyway but you might expose
your models you might send it to a
browser or to a device or at the very
least you're going to have an API which
can be able to which which user can be
able to enter interrogate your IP eyes
and maybe attackers may be about rather
access to this API too so you want to
have models and you want them not to
leak any information even if you have
some private information in your data
there's this concept which is called
different differential privacy and it's
a measurement mathematical framework to
like measure how much privacy
information you are leaking to the
outside world from a process so process
in general it could be a machine
learning processes could be a query
McBurney's mechanism we have a very nice
mathematical formula basically the idea
is that you've got two data sets there
are the same exercise one more person in
this second that I said one in the first
one and then you've got a query
mechanism or another model that model
algorithm which is K on this data set
and they got a probability distribution
which is quite close from
whereas it has been trained only on g1
or it contains the additional individual
in g2 so we certainly math the idea is
that if you've got if you're trained
your daddy on one data set or if you add
one dozen and you train your model again
you should have roughly the same model
that's why you have no way to know for
sure that the individual you added is in
the data set or not that's a way of
preserving privacy let's take an example
which is none not differential privates
a very nice thing
maximum a-posteriori so as long as
you're seeing only spam messages you
classify everything like spam so that's
that's a really stupid algorithm but if
you start seeing one sample which is not
spam then your algorithm which will
output something in probability so
you've got some randomness in the output
sometimes you start to output not spam
that means that if you have another
course we can query your your API you
can query this algorithm and they know
which was the last someone which was
added which is also something which is
possible then they know as soon as your
study to have non-spam responses that's
your last line added was not spam and
for spam or not spam it's not something
sensitive
now imagine that it's not about spam or
not spam but VIH status you definitely
want to protect the information but the
last year even if it's the last couple
of users I've might have VIH so how can
we do things better and be differential
private let's say you want to do a
survey and if your students cheated at
the test and it's just put out the
server and if it's anonymous and
everything you
probably not gonna get three honest
answers because you know nobody wants
that yes your ass treated to a test if
it's ever leaked you get into a lot of
trouble so instead you have just done to
do that they take a dice they fry it if
it's between one and five buzzie on
Summit roof if it's six they throw the
dice again and if it's odd they say yes
I cheated if it's and then they say no I
didn't cheat that way if the the survey
results are leaked with identifiers and
somehow you can get that to boost which
to the entrance and what they call I say
no I say I cheated on the survey but
that's just because I was unlucky with
the dice but I did not cheat so you can
press off the plausible deniability for
everyone and since you know the value of
P and K and you only care about the
aggregates value you can still recover
the number of students will treat it
with a limited loss of precision so
that's like win-win that's when you are
collecting but if you have like Oh Roger
that I said which is not differentially
private of course you can make a copy
and with the same kind of mechanism make
the copy differentially private and then
delete the first data set and then
you're good to go
differential privacy as I said is not an
algorithm it's like this general
mathematical framework so it's also
applies to when you are training the
model and in particular if you're using
stochastic gradient descent and a lot of
things are using stochastic resistance
to start just to start with deep
learning so it's always the same idea
you want to never be able to tell for
certain if a point was included in the
data set or not so you're gonna first
choose gradient beeping when you are
doing your updates
so that's each individual points as
limited influence on the global model
and then you're also going to add some
random noise so that's even if someone
gets access to all the updates they
cannot be
reverse injure that these updates to see
if one point was included into battlenet
if you don't want to reemployment that
from scratch there's a library which is
good for tensorflow
which is called privacy concern for
privacy and they implemented that they
also do all of the nasty accounting
stuff to measure what is your privacy
budget so that is how much of privacy
you lose by training your mother you
always lose some bit because as we said
Wow
we are trying to extract patterns so you
obviously do some privacy you've got
three additional power I prepare metals
to tune but other than that I mean it's
all implemented so it's not that hard to
set up in practice if you're not using
deep learning not using anything using a
stochastic gradient descents
they are some of a solution one of them
is called primary graduation of teacher
ensemble so the idea is you are going to
pass on your data and train several
models and there you've got two
different possibilities either all the
teachers are agreeing to the outcome and
this so these models versus teacher
models they are trying on different data
so you can imagine that reserve a strong
consensus that means you're not clicking
any privacy information because this in
the yellow and in Verret are totally
different individuals and you still get
to the same conclusion so that's okay
you're not taking information the other
case is well the teachers are
disagreeing so probably somewhere the
where as you add one individual or not
in the data set it changes the model
entirely and here you have got two
privates Alex so what do you do you you
make them vote but you add some noise if
there's a strong consensus the noise
doesn't matter because anyway it's
slower than the consensus if varies like
two and two so now I'm sure that you
say something yes and I know and you get
something which is probably deferential
private that's good but if you only
exposes the prediction but if you want
to deploy all of that then you've got to
deploy the individual teacher and the
teacher are not differentially private
so they can leak some information so
what you can do is instead of de praying
the teachers use the teachers to label
some public data why is it public
because you you get some data without
the sensitive attributes' and the
teachers are providing the sensitive
attributes and we've seen previously
that's with this mail noisy voting
mechanism which what we are providing is
differentiated private so basically what
you're getting here is prior privacy
preserving that is a data set containing
no private information which go back to
the first rule if you don't have any
private information it's very easy to do
privacy preserving machine learning and
then you can train the student model and
you can expose the student model to a
world it is it contains everything he
needs to do predictions and it cannot
leak anything because it has never seen
any private information the last thing
that you can encounter is that you want
to train some machine learning models
but you cannot do it in your own control
environment so it's in previously I can
anonymize data or you can ensure that
your models is not leaking any data but
if if you cannot train your model in the
control environment you have to ensure
that the training process is not leaking
any data there are two main use cases
the first one is that you've got a lot
of people having a bit of data not
enough to train a complete model but
they still want to collaborate to train
a model one solution is you got a
central server
she's updating a model starting and it
clients is stunning small updates and
the main summer is I'm arranging these
updates and sending back a new model and
then in a different client try improve
on the time I have this model and they
send out the updates and so on and so
forth you can do it in two ways one way
is you want choose to send everything in
clear because you think everybody is of
good faith the problem is that if your
central client is compromised then they
can possibly reverse engineers your
updates and gain some information using
for example generative investor or
network so ok ok you say ok I don't want
to send my updates in clear text so I'm
gonna encrypt everything and there are
some solutions and that's why you use
since everything you are sending is
encrypted
and the update is done on encrypted data
the main server is not about you to know
what you're sending them the problem is
then but the main server is also not
able to assert the good faith of the
clients and then it makes the world
system vulnerable to backdoor attacks
for example so it's an interesting
solution but you still have some
security issues and you have to be aware
of what's kind of environment you're
working in there a solution it's called
a mimosa encryption so my family laughs
oh mama forum isn't just like
malfunctions which are preserving
operations
so typically additional notification and
the idea is really very nice because
you're just kind of encrypt your data
and then you can send it to a third
party providers and they train your
model for you and then you get the
encrypted model and you decrypt it and
it's great because the third party
providers in the cloud they never see
your data and also you never see the
algorithm Val using so if it's like a
private eye
I don't want to expose it they can still
train models on your data we thought
single data and without you knowing what
they are using so infer it's just
perfect in practice in order to have
this very nicely
yeah in order to have this very nice
thing where every other size really
encrypted you want for example something
critical semantic safety that is to say
that on the ciphertext you cannot get
things like which are the most common by
its other kind of thing so you're gonna
have to add some noise and so you've got
a bit of noise on the each operation and
I've just too many operations the noise
drawn out the signal so that mean you
need to reset the noise level there is a
technique called bootstrapping which is
like basically you encrypt with a new
key and when you decrease with the
previous key and that way everything
stay encrypted but found out many
algorithms which are fully I mean I'm a
mafia algorithms which is also fully
palatable that's kind of the Holy Grail
also we're talking about addition and
multiplication which are a linear
operation but in cyclin brain your
neural network you've got activation
functions and these are typically
nonlinear operations so that means
you've got to send back the value the
encrypted value to the client the client
have to decrypt it doesn't the nonlinear
operation encrypt it again send it back
so a lot of encryption and decryption
and a lot of communication costs and
even we thought that the imam malik
encryption algorithms are available
right now the operation on ciphertext is
much much lower several order magnitude
slower than on clear text so it's like a
really neat idea but not right now it's
not practical maybe in the future gets
more research on that i hope we get
something that's yeah
I want you to talk about that so in a
nutshell that's always a craft part when
you say things you already said it again
but maybe not clearly enough thing is if
you want to anonymize your that ice hard
and it's not on structural data on
tableau data it's even harder on texts
that are unstructured data it's hard to
do it perfectly that does not make that
do it li doing it in perfectly is a
waste of time I mean anything that can
you know you've got encryption and then
if you removed as much information as
possible and then you ensure that your
model is not leaking too much
information that's better to a free
layer of protection than only one which
you know is might be saying the other
thing is always each case is whether
you're using a dictionary based approach
or named entity recognition things like
typical American names are probably
going to get recognized pretty easily
but anything which is like non-american
sounding names it might be much harder
and these people also might come from
minorities we're leaking their
information might be more dramatic for
them than for someone which is more
privileged in the society so you should
really like see how your less privileged
rarer users are protected by your
algorithm because you're also doing that
for them
that's nice thing about your the census
you should still do a proper cutting
because even if in theory your algorithm
is perfectly differential private and
you've done all the math and you're like
regrets more privacy projects perfect
and you've got the stupid bugs that's
gonna rinse off your effort so do
testing and write readable code and do
refactoring and you know just do good
software engineering
and there's always these trade-offs
between well actually having protecting
privacy and kind of well getting things
done fast and getting things done I
correctly if you start to worry about
are you anonymizer data set why you lose
a bit of time in your pipeline so of
obviously if as a trader if you're
dealing with medical data you need to do
that if you're just dealing with the
number of stuff like on snapshot maybe
you shouldn't
I mean find the right trade-off for your
application but yeah I think the golden
rules very quickly some open questions
so the impact of a use case we already
talked about that they're starting to be
something like on medical reports they
estimate the loss of concept a clinical
concept to under three percent so it's
not entirely negligible is quite small
once again depend of your application
where is this wall broad area for self
of generic of generating price of a
privacy preserving synthetic data but
then what's our guarantees if you
guarantee is that's what you've seen the
original data set is never in the
synthetic data it's not reprise
privacy-preserving because if you
generate a lot a lot of fantastic that I
you you see in in the whole we have true
that I was but then if you generate some
the time which is too similar to the
true data eyes it's still
privacy-preserving and there's this
always this question like you want to
print off privacy but that means if you
want to have really a metric to do that
you have to solve some in notation at
some time so you have to have at first a
human looking from
through private data to ensure that the
future that you're gonna get is gonna be
protected but there is this tension
between that so ii haven't talked a lot
a lot about via spam problems but maybe
you want to use them by your members the
mail very good price
[Music]
if you ask them some Christians it's
like online and they've got a bit of
bibliography if you want to no matter
what know more about the subject thank
you thank you very much Tara great
practical case especially for privacy
which I think everyone should appreciate
very much
so QA hi thank you for the presentation
do you sample noise from in distribution
or do you have any other methods for
sampling the noise in your
implementation the noise you mean for
you show some methods these are for
annotation strengths the methods well
which my question is how do you sample
your noise how do you define noise in
your system in like differential privacy
stuff yeah differential practice stuff
yeah
you usually generate noise using like
you generate losing apps or the random
generator which is provided like a
diamond pie or is possible to generate
noise from any a discrete or continuous
distributions yes you you choose if you
want to so typically you use Gaussian
noise for continuous distribution and if
you have a discrete distribution well I
guess you have to set some fresh
automobiles and do some permutation all
that kind of things but if you're using
stochastic gradient descent you're
working on continuous values anyway okay
so you can add some Gaussian noise okay
thank you more questions
in matters like this I'm always really
curious when you have written a model or
written an algorithm that does something
that a human can do perfectly
and do you have a metric for written
text of inter-house it called the
Intelsat or exactly that just something
rough well 3i I thought everything else
all right now I know that some matrix
that exists is that something well I
don't have any specific algorithm to
recommend or sorry anyone else um when
dealing with and when dealing with
obscuring information in text how do you
deal with longer currents chains well
yes that's a good question actually
I don't talk too much about that that's
actually yeah you you can say when
you're doing like names your akane-chan
just say this is a person and this is a
person but probably you might need to
know that this is person 1 and this is
person too and this is person 1 again
when solution is it's the name of the
same image the tokens are very similar
just to keep like a dictionary while you
are doing this named entity recognition
and then replace it if it's sign on sign
our names so like first mister
name surname and then you just have mr.
surname or some kind of synonyms like
mr. director of things writes how do you
you have to when certain is to add some
semantic information so as a knowledge
graph outside of it so that you know
that's the prisoners of United States is
Donald Trump and then you can match what
is the same person yeah that's that's it
okay final find a question someone was
not sitting way over there no one also
good community space what we're just the
question so I mean as a data scientists
we all know that we should use this like
an organization and like
privacy-preserving
approaches in your experience like are
the companies that do that or like is it
something that's still like more an
objective than actual I think it depends
a lot of the companies I know a lot of
companies are like doing roughly
siddhanam ization
and they think it's more than enough
because like if a GDP are compliant so
that's good and some of our companies
well some of us say that privacy is our
main concern and that's just marketing
talk and some are really caring about
that and yeah it's something I mean like
all we've got this great keynote this
morning about ethical rules we sure are
implements I think it's so from us that
a sense is to say okay this matter and I
won't deploy this in production as long
as there is not this minimum level of
work which has been done on the topic
obviously it's not possible at every
stage if you're like very small start-up
but just should still consider that as
soon as you're using some data you
you're like becoming responsible for
this data and if there's a major data
leak
would you feel can you still you know
get up in the morning and think you're a
good person or not and you should not
say that it's our way and it's diluted
responsibility yeah sure but it's also
directed responsibly does not mean no
responsibility yeah so I guess it's a
very personal question but perfect
perfect ending yeah make sure that when
you wake up you're a good person
thank you very much
[Applause]